for more on the alleged plot we're
joined by michigan attorney general dana
nessel good morning attorney general
how close were these suspects to
actually carrying out this plot
well they had all the means to do it
they had been in training exercises
we think they had the necessary
equipment artillery
explosives things of that nature um and
we thought the trainings had gone on
long enough and as i
as i like to say i'd rather have the
weakest conspiracy
case rather than the strongest homicide
and we were very concerned that it was
moving
towards uh action but that being the
case i this is not a weak case these are
very compelling and strong cases
um and clearly this was not just talk
these were many overt
actions uh and so we thought it was time
to move in
uh before anybody lost their lives and
when was the governor made aware of this
plot against her
uh we've been consistently updating the
governor as events occurred over the
course of the last couple months
so she was aware of things that were
happening uh at times
she and her family had been moved around
uh
as a result of activities that um you
know
law enforcement was aware of oh that's
interesting
uh as jeff begaye pointed out there were
13 people charged overall six federally
seven by the state
uh and and it's not it wasn't just a
plot against the governor
uh they attempted to identify home
addresses of law enforcement officers
and intended to instigate civil war do
you expect
more people could be charged in this
case
well let's just say this the the state
and the federal authorities have been
working together
we have a task force and there are a lot
of groups
that we've been looking at a lot of
individuals we've been looking at um
so when you ask if they we can expect
further charges i don't know that they
will be associated necessarily with
the this particular group but certainly
do i expect further charges
um related to this uh
series of groups that seem to be
operating together not just
in the state of michigan um but across
several states and many jurisdictions
yes i do
governor whitmer accused president trump
of being
complicit implementing extremism the
president
said it was my justice department that
brought charges
what's your take on this well i will say
this um
you know i've had the opportunity to
work with federal authorities uh many
times over the years uh
you know as a state prosecutor and we've
always enjoyed a good working
relationship
uh so irrespective of who the president
is
yeah you know these federal law
enforcement
agencies and officers take their jobs
very seriously
but that being the case i will say it's
very unhelpful
when you have a group of these
individuals um
armed to the teeth who storm our state
capital hovering
over our state senators and threatening
them
uh and then the governor sorry the the
president calls them very good people
who the governor should sit down and
negotiate with
and it turns out of course these were
the same people that ultimately were
charged so
um i i can't imagine being a person in
that position of authority and i will
say as the top law enforcement official
in this state i can't imagine seeing
people who behave in that matter and
then encouraging them
and in fact indicating that our governor
should negotiate with them i think
that's fundamentally
unhelpful from a law enforcement
perspective do you think the president
understands the power of of his words
when he speaks this way that people it
people may hear his words very
differently than he intends them to be
um i don't know if he doesn't understand
the power of his words
uh or if he does very well understand
the power of his words
and he's trying to incite some sort of
chaos or our anarchy
that frankly these groups thrive upon um
but
either way you know i guess my message
would be
uh to him and to any other elected
leaders that sort of traffic
in this sort of rhetoric to understand
the power of their words
and that when they say these things
people not only listen but they respond
and so some of the things that i've
heard
the president say over the course of the
last several years
um especially at the debate even last
week
i i i would say i think that it's not
just a dog whistle but sometimes even a
rallying cry
for these types of organization and
these types of individuals who are very
bad actors
that seek to harm others and damage
frankly american society
attorney general dana nessl thank you so
much for being with us this morning we
appreciate it
thank you for having me